I'm tomato pooja and the director of
CBMM which is hosting this talk back in
2011
Josh and I organized Josh is there one
of the symposia for the MIT hundred 50
anniversary and the simple teemo's
brains minds and machines and the last
day was the most exciting day of the
symposium was that about the marketplace
for intelligence who invited some of the
big companies like IBM Microsoft Google
and so on and a couple of startups one
was mobile I and you have heard from
unknown yesterday about the state of
autonomous driving the other one was
deep mind and and Demi's spoke then he
had been a postdoc for a short period of
time with me and at Harvard and he was
at CBMM in what was already done at the
heart of machine learning at MIT
deme spoke then about the unofficial
business plan of deepmind which was to
create the first day I in the virtual
world of games since then you have come
back a few times to keep up updated
about the progress of deepmind and last
time I think was three years ago and
this was shortly after alphago won the
competition in South Korea in Seoul
against Lee SEDOL
and so this time they missed made just
very well declare victory and in the
virtual world of games because they've
done everything you know beyond all
hopes maybe will issue a new business
plan and you challenge for the real
world we see I have often said that
intelligence the problem of intelligence
is the greatest problem
in science today and tomorrow and this
also means is not going to be
particularly easy to solve it
I think it's not only one problem but
like like biology the science of life in
the same way the science of intelligence
is a lot of problems we will need a lot
of break rules not one but many Nobel
Prizes
so both damage and CBMM share the view
that neuroscience and cognitive science
would be at the core of progress that
ultimately lead to developed
understanding better human intelligence
and developing intelligent machines the
journey may be longer than many people
think but it will be very rewarding in
many different ways intellectually and
otherwise and we should enjoy this
journey and enjoy making history
so please welcome Demi's
thanks Tommy
hope you can all hear me okay thanks all
of you for for coming it's amazing to
see see you all here and it's always
really fun for me to come back to MIT
and catch up with old friends and also
see how much amazing work CBMM and all
of you are doing both in neuroscience as
well as machine learning and and in the
crossover which is very close to my
heart so today what I thought I'd talk
about I mean there's lots of things I
could discuss that we've done since I
was last here three years ago but I
entitled the talk the power of self
learning systems because I think what
we've and others have shown over the
last years is how surprisingly useful
they can be and how powerful quite a
simple idea can end up being so I'm just
going to talk about the beginning with
framing you know I've always thought
about AI as if effectively bifurcating
into two different types of approaches
and this is when we think about AI in
the history of AI and on the one hand
you know we can try to build expert
systems that rely on hard-coded
knowledge that basically are hand
crafted with the solution to a problem
but and they're usually inspired by
logic systems and mathematics and that
for a long time was the way that most
people attempted to build AI and the
problem with that is that those kinds of
systems can't deal with the unexpected
they basically usually fail
catastrophically if something hasn't
already been programmed into them if
they encounter something unusual or that
the programmer had not foreseen and the
other nation interesting issue is that
of course they're limited in scope to
the sorts of solutions that we are able
to articulate we as the human
programmers so of course by definition
they're limited to these pre-programmed
solutions on the other hand and I think
why this is such an exciting moment in
scientific history and while you're here
is that there's been this sort of big
Renaissance if you like or
of the learning system approach where
instead of programming solutions we and
we build systems that are able to learn
for themselves from first principles
learn their own solutions to problems
and what we hope is that these systems
will be sufficiently general they can
generalize to all sorts of new tasks
perhaps tasks they've never seen before
and actually indeed even solve things
that we as human scientists are not able
to do right so maybe the promise of
these systems is that they could go
beyond what we able to solve on our own
and I'm going to talk about that in the
in the latter part of this talk now
officially in learning systems and why I
think what CBMM is is doing is so great
and also what we do at deep mind is that
we can look to the best learning system
we have the brain human brain and see if
we can be inspired by understanding that
better inspired about new algorithms
that we could use new representations
new architectures they're inspired by
neuroscience and our understanding of
the brain in complete though that is and
I would say not only can we be inspired
but we can also validate algorithms that
we've come up with ourselves from
perhaps from mathematical approaches or
physics approaches in orthogonal
approaches from neuroscience if we get
build a system like that reinforcement
learning I think is a good example of
that which was pushed forward in
engineering quite a lot in the in the
80s and 90s we can then see you know
when we find that the brain implements a
form of DTB learning in some famous
results in the 90s you know we could be
confident then that reinforcement
learning and is plausibly part of a kind
of overall AI solution and so we can
push harder on those techniques if we
know that the brain also uses those
techniques and that point of validation
is often overlooked but it's very
important when you are running or in
charge of a big engineering program you
know where do you decide to put more
effort in if something doesn't work
which you know things often don't work
first time or even many times in
research and engineering how much more
should you push that approach and if you
can take some guidance from from the
brain and some comfort that these
systems are
the brain does implement them then that
can be very important source of
information so as Tommy mentioned last
time I was here and maybe some of you
were in the audience three years ago now
we just come off fresh off the back of
our big alphago match and that we played
in seoul and really overturned a lot of
the traditional thinking in the game of
go but also was very surprising to many
people in AI and many of the experts
sort of proclaim that this was a decade
before they expected it to happen so I'm
not going to talk about alphago today
but if you're interested in a sort of
behind-the-scenes look at what happened
with alphago in the whole project I'd
recommend this documentary that was done
by his award-winning documentary was
done by a great filmmaker who followed
us behind the scenes and had access
behind the scenes at all during this
journey and it's on Netflix and Amazon
now in other places and I'd recommend
you take a look at that if you're
interested in that story so today I'm
going to focus on what we've been doing
in the last 12 months and it's been
quite a watershed year for us at deep
mind and we've had quite a few
interesting breakthroughs then I'm going
to cover today so the first thing I talk
about is alpha 0 and alpha zero is our
latest incarnation of the alphago
program as well a series of programs so
I'm just going to show you for those of
you don't know the lineage of alpha zero
and how we came about working on this
project so first of all there was the
original alphago so this is three three
plus years ago now and alphago was
amazingly strong but we had to do a
bootstrapping step which was to learn
from human games first by predicting
what human players not experts but
strong amateurs that we downloaded some
games of from online databases and we
tried to initially train on your network
systems to predict what the human player
would do sort of by mimicking these
human players and then once it got sort
of reasonably strong like weak amateur
level then we started this process of
self play and self learning by playing
against itself to improve
but what we wanted to do is and the way
we work at deep mind is we try to we
always got generality in mind that's the
final goal like the kind of purist
system you can build with the least
amount of assumptions in it about and
and a maximally general that works
across as many possible domains as
possible without any adjustment so we
start off you know can go be cracked at
all that was obviously the original
question then once we did alphago then
we looked at all the components of the
system when we saw we sort of try some
systematic work then to remove all the
things that were specific to go right
there were still left remaining specific
to go so the next step was what we
called alphago zero and and what we did
here is remove this initial step of
needing some human games to bootstrap
form from the beginning so alphago zero
started from totally random play and
improved all the way to become stronger
than the original alphago just through
self play just from playing millions of
games against itself and modifying its
new or network based on whether it won
or lost so and so zero here refers to
the use of zero human knowledge
domain-specific knowledge obviously we
need a human knowledge to make the
system but we didn't use any go specific
knowledge was required and that's
important because eventually if we want
to use these systems for real-world
problems you know you may not have a
treasure trove of data like millions of
human amateur games that are freely
downloadable on the internet you may not
have access or you may not there may not
be that kind of data so you might have
to generate it itself and then the final
step which were going to talk a little
bit about in this section was our four
zero so now we drop the word go because
alpha zero is able to play any
two-player perfect information game to
world champion or a higher standard and
I put the asterisks on any because we
only tried it with three the three the
three biggest games that are played
professionally so chess which I'm going
to talk about a lot and uses the
canonical example go
so alpha zero can be alphago zero and
shogi Japanese chess which is
really amazing of version of chess
that's very different from western chess
but extremely complex as well and played
professionally in Japan so I'm going to
talk about alpha zero and you can see so
this there's this sort of framing of
increasing generality alphago first
remove all the ghosts Pacific and human
data components of that and then finally
generalized to any two-player game now
as you all know chess nai has had a long
and storied history starting from the
very the dawn of modern computing von
Neumann Turing Shan and all of many of
my scientific heroes even including
Babbage actually going all the way back
all tried their hand at chess programs
many in Turing's case he wrote it out on
piece of paper and executed it himself
but but but he say wasn't you know a
computer program as such but but he you
know he he tried his hand at that and
they all imagined what you know a strong
chess program might be like and in fact
guest Gary Kasparov recently wrote in
his editorial for our science paper that
chess is has always been or isn't can be
thought of as like a Drosophila of
reasoning and I I sort of agree with him
on that actually that's definitely the
kind of places occupied for many years
in AI research now what you can argue of
course chess has been done right I mean
it was done in the late 90s when
famously IBM deep blue beat Garry
Kasparov
in in a six-game match so at that point
and since that point chess programs have
been stronger than then he the best
human players and indeed as has changed
the way that we play chess but so you
could argue well why did we bother
trying to to apply alpha zero to chess
when we already know machines can beat
the world champion in chess so this is
unlike go where obviously there was no
program that could be the the go world
champion now the reason is and this was
a debate I had actually with one of the
project leaders on deep blue when back
in 2016 when we just done alphago I
think we haven't actually yet done the
Lisa doll match but we've done the fan
play match and I gave a talk at triple
AI and at the end
Marie Campbell
was one of the project leads on IBM deep
blue came up to me afterwards and
congratulated us on on alphago but asked
me the question of like what do you
think will happen if we apply this to
chess would you know is it possible for
these learnt systems to be stronger than
the handcrafted systems that have had
thirty years of incredible engineering
being done on them plus the distillation
of many hundreds of grandmasters right
so this is one of the most I'd argue
chess computers is one of the most
heavily engineered areas in all of AI
right I think it's been probably the
longest standing continuous domain
that's been worked on and they're
obviously incredibly strong and even as
a chess player myself a next chess
player myself I was wondering was chess
rich enough as a game to have enough
exploration left for for a learned
system to learn some new ideas and
perhaps some new theories or themes
about the game that would allow it to
compete with these really big brutes of
a machines now that we have that
incredibly optimized to brute-force
search through through chess moves so
you know actually we both concluded in a
discussion that we didn't know the
answer to this you know would it be able
to be competitive is there enough room
in chess for this kind of stuff when I
asked my strong chess player friends
they didn't know either so to me that's
always a good sign of a great scientific
question we're basically either answer
is very illuminating a very interesting
so we decided to to try and do that now
just to give you an example of how
amazing and kind of carefully these
current chess engines are written the
current world champion or at least when
we were doing these tests the 2016 world
champion is a program called stop fish
and it's in the lineage it's an
open-source programmers in the lineage
of deep blue these kinds of systems and
they have hundreds of rules and even
thousands of handcrafted rules about
chess porn structures and King safety
all different things evaluation the
teams of programmers over many years
have tried to distill from human
grandmasters and and encapsulate in
these complex database of rules and then
of course they have to balance those
rules against each other
so there's a phenomenal amount of
engineering has gone into this and then
obviously
of optimization to make these systems as
fast as possible so they can actually
look at tens of millions of moves per
decision they have to make and then they
have opening databases and endgame
databases that tell you that exactly
solve both the opening and the end and
especially the endgame seven pieces or
less has been solved so you just have a
lookup table now that's what a chess
engine looks like today that's what
we're confronting when we try and build
a learning system that could compete
against that what we do is we throw a
all those thousands of handcrafted rules
and and that handcrafted knowledge and
all that chest knowledge and we replace
it with two things self play we enforce
at learning and Monte Carlo tree search
that's it so such a very simple program
once you've once you've built it and and
and optimized it so I'm just quickly
going to go through how alpha zero works
for those who don't you know I'm
actually going to compound together
alpha zero and alphago zero because
they're slightly different systems but
they're pretty much trained in the same
way so I don't want to go through this
twice but you can kind of imagine it's a
bit of a hybrid what I'm going to
describe between alphago 0 and alpha
zero so what you do is first of all you
create your your-your-your neural
network architecture and in alphago we
used to have two neural networks one
that chose narrowed down the likely
moves that will be played in a certain
position we call that the policy network
and then another neural network that
learned to evaluate the current position
and who was winning and the probability
chance of which side was going to win by
alphago 0 and alpha 0 we managed to
merge these two neural networks into one
your network that output two values sort
of had two outputs the the the most
likely moves to search and and this and
this evaluation and that allows the tree
search to be very efficient which I'll
come back to the end much more efficient
than we have to do with traditional
chess engines because we can both reduce
the the width of the search by using the
policy network to narrow down to the
most likely moves and we can reduce the
depth of the search by truncating the
search at any point and of using the
value calling the value Network and
evaluating the position at that point so
we start with that has no knowledge
about anything we do hundred thousand
gate games sort of in batches of self
play of the current best version of our
neural network against itself hundred
thousand times roughly that creates a
big training corpus of data synthetic
training data obviously in this case
every hundred thousand or so batches we
then try to train a new neural network
based off of the old training data and
the new training data and then we create
this new neural network and then this
new neural network we play it roughly a
hundred times against or maybe a
thousand times against the old neural
network and at the point when it wins
55% of the time then we replace the old
neural network with the new one so if it
doesn't beat the old neural network more
than fifty five percent of the time we
do the next hundred thousand games with
the old network so now we have two
hundred thousand to train the new neural
network and so on
until eventually the neural network the
new neural network is better if it is
better than he gets ripley replaces the
old one and now the new network is what
we use to generate the next batch of
self play data and so on and this this
pretty simple regime is incredibly
powerful and you can bootstrap from
random to world champion level and above
in a matter of hours with this system
from literally starting from random play
so in chess this requires about forty
million games we play a game in about
three seconds
that's a that's that's an interesting
tuning sort of parameter because what
you could do is you could allow the
neural network in these training games a
longer amount of time to think then
obviously the games would be higher
quality but you would have let but it
would take you longer to generate the
games so you'd have less games in a
certain amount of time so that's an
interesting trade-off that is still not
clear what the right trade-off is there
we're still doing some experiments on
that and then we play 5000 games at a
time on 5,000 TP use which we have
access to but obviously if you had less
computers you would have less games at a
time and it would just take longer so
with this amount of compute it only
takes a few hours so that's alpha 0
that's the bay
SiC training and then we tend tested it
under match conditions which is in our
size paper we talk to stop fish creators
and we got the exact conditions they use
for their World Championship matches
this is stock fish ate I should say so
there's now stock fish ten but two years
ago stock fish eight was the world
champion and we won the thousand game
match one hundred fifty five wins two
six losses so and the rest draws but you
know chess is a very Jewish game but but
but that's a big margin one hundred
fifty five to six and actually when you
look at the six games what you find out
in those is it's generally drawn
positions where alpha zero has pressed
too hard for win so so that's another
interesting thing about how much should
we reward a win to a draw and that
that's another interesting thing that we
could discuss in the Q&A that we've we
played around with so so it's
convincingly stronger and by the way it
surpasses stock fish in four hours from
starting from random so this is the
graph of improvement there that you can
see so all this decades of you know
human handcrafted programming can be
learned well a different knowledge can
be learnt in a matter of hours and then
we tried it on shogi and we beat the the
world's best shogi program which is
roughly human world champion level in a
couple of hours and in go we were able
to be alphago for go zero in eight hours
of training with this new more efficient
architecture so so we believe this would
work on any two-player perfect
information game which I have to say was
one of my always one of my childhood
dreams because I used to play lots of
different games as well as chess and we
always just talked about what would the
kind of master games player be and and
those of you read any hermann hesse the
gillaspie game is one of my favorite
books I recommend that to all of you and
that in there is about a you know the
beauty of games and and in this case a
an intellectual getting incredible at a
game and then using that to solve many
other domains so so for me this was
always a waypoint that I've been
dreaming about for a long time
and and I think we've got there now now
the the interesting thing is that well
there's many interesting things to say
actually and I only only cover a few the
interesting things now maybe we can go
more into this in the Q&A but one thing
to look at is the amount of search the
efficiency of these systems and the
amount of search per decision now
there's lots of ways of measuring
efficiency and obviously the human brain
is incredibly energy efficient and these
systems are not both the chair normal
chess engines and things like alpha zero
certainly not compared to human
Grandmaster but what I'm more interested
in actually is the compute efficiency or
the sample efficiency and traditional
chess engines like it the ones that you
can run on your PC at home now are so
optimized they can look at 10 million
moves order of tens of millions of moves
per decision they have to make now if we
compare that to a human Grandmaster on
the left there you know the top
grandmasters look at maybe maybe the
order of a couple of hundred moves with
each decision they have to make so many
orders of magnitude less than the
computer engines do and what's
interesting is alpha 0 is sort of it's
not as efficient as a human Grandmaster
not by a long shore hundred Exmoor but
it's it's in the middle alpha zero looks
at the order of tens of thousands of
moves before making a decision not tens
of millions so so I think that's
interesting directionally too to think
about there so you know another
interesting test that you can do is if
you turn off all the search completely
right you can kind of measure how strong
these engines are and with the chess
engines if you turn off if you get rid
of their search so just just immediate
just just using their evaluation
function they're terrible they're
they're like weaker than a weak club
player so you know just just about know
how to play chess and but alpha zero if
you turn a halt it's search it's roughly
International Master standard so it's
pretty good even though it's not even
without any search whatsoever and we
think we can make that stronger
- but what's also cool for those of you
play chess is the way alpha0 place so we
saw this in alphago alphago came up with
these amazing new themes and motifs that
the human go players had never seen and
are now using by all accounts but this
was the answering so the first part of
the question was answered can we that
Marie asked me you know can we build a
learning system that can compete with
these brute-force search engine type
systems and the answer is yes
handcrafted systems and the second
question is you know what's the richness
of chess itself as a domain and what was
amazing and really pleasing to see is
that alpha zero played in this very
unique style and there's actually many
unique things about it but the main key
difference between alpha zero and the
way that chess engines play is the alpha
zero really favors mobility of its
pieces versus materiality so the chess
engines really like material and they're
known to be you know mid grabbing
materials if you give it a pawn it will
always take the pawn and then the thing
about those systems was they were quite
ugly to the human eye to the human
expert aesthetically because what these
engines would do is they would grab
material greedily grab material get into
a kind of bad looking positional
position but have more material and
because they were so good tactically
they couldn't be beaten even though the
moves they were making looked a bit ugly
to a human expert of course in the end
the chess players concluded maybe they
just the computer just knew better
because ultimately was stronger and
perhaps our intuition of beauty just
doesn't map to functionality but what
alpha0 did was it plays in this very
dynamic and to human Grandmaster
aesthetically beautiful style and it's
able to beat this sort of kind of
calculation style that the engines have
and and that really excited the chess
world and in fact is rekindled my
passion for chess and I've been playing
a lot more recently and got the the
chess players really excited and for
those of you play chess this is my
favorite position from the alpha zero
stop fish games alpha zero is white stop
fish is black and alpha zero loves
sacrificing pieces
and we can maybe talk a little bit about
why that is in a second but it loves
sacrificing pieces to get more mobility
for its remaining pieces and this is the
perfect example of that in in in chess
there's this term german term called
zugzwang which means that you've got
your opponent into a position where any
move they make will make their position
worse
right that's what a zoogs Whang means
and what alpha0 has done here for those
you know chess is it swapped its rook
for a bishop rooks are worth five points
bishop sir were only worth three points
and it's done that so it can see loft
black's queen in the corner you can see
the queen hopefully this pointer right
in the corner can't move and these two
rooks are stuck because they have to
defend this pawn next to the King
because all of white's pieces are gang
up against it none of its pawns can move
without being taken so basically in the
King Kong move so nothing can move in
this position so somehow it's like alpha
zero is hermetically sealed stop fishing
and literally it can't move so so it
just has to give up its pieces so this
is kind of incredible like and obviously
alpha zero has foreseen this you know 10
20 moves beforehand that it was going to
get into this situation and we're
literally stopped fish cannot do
anything now one reason you might might
think you know what we can debate how
come
alpha zero can do this more freely and
some by the way in human history some
amazing chess players some world
champions were famous for doing this
this guy called mikhail tal were in the
60s was world champion and he was famous
for making extraordinary sacrifices and
winning these very beautiful games and
alpha zero is sort of in that style and
and if you think about it in a normal
chess engine one of the first rules you
would build into a chess engine if
you're writing them and i used to write
these in when i was a kid like different
different types of engines you'd write
the piece values in right so you'd say
rook is five points knight is three
points and you would total up one of the
first things you would do for your
search engine is to basically total up
what each side has got and it's better
to have more points right so if you
think about it if a chess engine normal
chess engine wants to sacrifice a rook
for a knight yeah it's - it's it's hard
code of rule is telling it that's - two
points so somewhere down the line
through its tens of millions of
calculations it's got to figure out
that it's going to get two points of
value back like like objectively figure
that out
by some other rule right or or capture
that that that material back or more and
so that's very constraining if you think
about it right where's our four zero
doesn't have that in book rule so it
doesn't have to overcome this inbuilt
bias that this that is about to make
this sacrifice in it's worth - its - two
points as far as its concerned rooks are
just assets nights are just assets they
move in different ways right now your
opponent's Knight is in an outpost and
really powerful my rooks passive and not
doing much so I'm going to swap it right
it can take into account context which
the handcrafted rules obviously can't
doesn't matter how many rules you would
program in you can't go in this position
in this specific case with the Queen in
the corner then then you know it's okay
to sacrifice right I mean you could try
and people have tried but it wouldn't be
ready general that rule you probably
need millions and millions and millions
of rules to encapsulate that and then on
top of that think about something else
how are you going to balance all those
rules against each other right how are
you going to balance material versus
pawn structure versus Kings safety all
of these kind of fairly esoteric
concepts and obviously can have a go at
doing that with grandmasters telling you
what they think but it's very difficult
even human grandmasters don't think in
that way right they can't perfectly
balance these things together within a
few decimal points so so I think there's
many reasons why alpha 0 is and this
style of program is stronger then we
showed it to the kind of code at all of
this is we showed it to one of my old
chess friends Matthew Sadler and Natasha
Regan - my chess friends from Cambridge
and Matthew saddle owes two times
British champion and we laid that we let
them in before we published the paper to
look at all the self play games and they
found that there were so many
interesting new motifs that alpha zero
had found there were seven new themes
that they hadn't really seen before in
professional chess and they were they
really asked have petitioned us to kind
of write a chess book about these new
ideas and that's just come out in
January so if you any of your chess
players I'd recommend this book
game-changer which talks about how these
new ideas and why they're so exciting
and and Garry Kasparov also wrote some
very nice things about this and and and
very interested in AI and one thing he
wrote was about alpha zero as programs
usually reflect priorities and
prejudices of programmers but because
alpha zero learns for itself I would say
its style reflects the truth which is
quite an amazing statement really of
course he went on to say that it plays
like him which he was very perhaps he's
a bit bias and I think it does a little
bit but he was very pleased to say that
as well later on in the article so
that's alpha zero so I want to move on
now to alpha star which is our newest
program so you can think well ok you
know we've done board games Perl and I
was very clear to caveat with perfect
information two-player games right so
that's quite a big you know why branch
of things encompasses a lot of human
activity in the games domain but you
know it's still there still easy in some
sense right and in two ways that they're
easy to important ways that they're easy
is that the state transitions are very
simple right you make a move it's pretty
clear what the next state is going to
look at and they're perfect information
so there's no hidden information and
partial observe observe ability so we
wanted to tackle these two challenges
that we feel are beyond what we did with
alphago in the Alpha zero series of
programs and so we wanted to pick in a
domain that was sort of more complex and
a dynamic real-time environment that
also had hidden information and to do
that we chose the game of Starcraft 2
which you know many of you will be fans
of and you know you can ask why did we
choose Starcraft 2 well for several
reasons
in my opinion in widely-held sort of
acknowledged it's the most complex and
most exquisitely balanced realtime
strategy game I think ever made and
realtime strategy games are kind of the
hardest of the strategy games in in the
computer games world it was also the
first eSport so it's been professionally
over a decade so there are many hundreds
of professionals a lot of them in Korea
again like with the go programs a go
player sorry and and there's been played
very very high-level it's also been
quite a classic challenge for AI
for about a decade as well so people
have been researching Starcraft AI and
having organizing global competitions
from about 2010 a lot of the first work
came out of Berkley and also we had good
relationship with Blizzard who make this
fantastic game and they were able to
supply us with things like anonymize
replays of human games and they were
very excited about exploring this for
their own for their own games
development if they can build AI in this
way for games that would save them a
huge amount of time and effort and so
the new challenges are partially
observable as I mentioned massive action
space so this is another new challenge
compared to ball games it's you know
it's not a good way of estimating this
but we estimated there's roughly 10 to
the power 8 possible actions per per
move if you like although it's real-time
and then there's very long-term
dependency so games can last like half
an hour and they can involve more than
5,000 steps 10,000 steps this kind of
range which obviously a lot more than a
board game which is in the order of 100
to 200 moves and it's real-time and
multiplayer the other thing about this
game is that the way you play it it's a
very dynamic game so unlike a board game
where this the set of pieces is fixed at
the start like in chess here in in
Starcraft and these kinds of realtime
strategy games you build up your army
and your your-your-your units so every
game is different so there's basically
four steps in in in Starcraft step one
is you collect your resources you build
a base you build your units and then you
you battle with your opponent and so
there's a very complex game with many
many rich strategies and there are three
different alien races you can play which
is so that there's a kind of Paper
Scissors stone element so it's very
complicated game to play and in terms of
our architecture I haven't got time to
go into this in detail but we'll be
publishing a paper on this soon and
which will have all that all the details
but basically there are three
feed-forward networks that take in the
various observations so their spatial
observations about the map there's
there's various numbers that keep track
of your economy how many resources
you've collected and and so on and then
there's information about your units how
many are there's like 50 different types
of units you can build how many have you
got
of each type and how many are you
producing and so those 3 feed-forward
networks you can see here I'll piped
into a deep LS TM which is really the
core of the system and it has three
layers of s 2 LS TMS and and a bunch of
other stuff and then the output is a
function head which is you know what
action to take and then that
parameterised across the units using the
attention mechanism so you can think of
this as a parameterised function that's
output you know move these 5 units to
this position and that's what what is
output and then and then you see that
being executed now in terms of the
training we created this thing called
alpha starleague which is we call this
population based training and really
this is kind of like self play on
steroids because instead of now just
playing against yourself one opponent we
have an entire league of diverse
competitors that you are competing
against so so at the beginning we start
with the first agent that we build and
that started by imitation learning so in
supervised learning by looking at the
replay games that we got from Blizzard
so this is human data actually not not
that strong those players so they were
like median level human players and then
we create our first agent here 0 0 1
which is which is created by imitation
but then we fought this agent and we
start using our self play and
reinforcement learning to to improve the
level of this agent so this is very much
how we started like with alphago except
in this case we also keep around older
agents the ones in blue to make sure
that we as we improve our to new
strategies we don't forget to be our old
strategies and and then this this level
improvement carries on for you know
about thousand or more different epochs
as we keep increasing the strength of
these systems and then at the end before
we challenge the top human players what
we do is we we take what we call the
nash of the league so we look at if we
have five matches we take the best five
strategies and the ones that basically
together dominate the rest of the league
but are not dominated by any other
individual agent in that still that's
outside of that nash those five so and
then those are the ones we take into the
competition now one one way we kind of
increase the amount of diversity in our
systems is by introducing intrinsic
motivation so obviously the a the AI
systems get rewarded but for winning
again but we also to increase diversity
we also give them some pseudo rewards or
intrinsic motivations and these can be
make sure you build X number of units
and then win right so there's like fifty
different units as I'll saying so we can
we can kind of make AI system make some
of the agents specialize in certain
types of units we can also say you know
only focus on beating this one other
agent in the league so it can kind of
pick on one agent and and we can sort of
randomize that a bit as well so we can
kind of introduce asymmetries in all
sorts of ways and we're still
experimenting with different ways a very
rich area to look at designing pseudo
rewards and evolving them potentially
and what you get is if you see this
graph is this is the nut this is the
different units you can build or a
selection of them it's like 25 things
here and this is the number of days of
training the league and this is how many
the sort of height of this graph is how
many of those units were built at
different stages of the league training
by all of the different agents that were
active at that moment in time and you
can see that the different strategies
urban flow depending on which one is
dominant at the time so once we did that
just before Christmas last year we
decided we were ready to take on some of
the top professionals in the world so we
invited in two of the top professionals
TLO and manna from from a German team
and and they came in and tested our our
system behind closed doors in some in
two official five-game matches and here
is you can
see the progress of of alpha star each
of these dots is one of the agents in
the Alpha Star League and you can see
how they're improving these are all the
rankings human rankings after from
bronze to Grandmaster and obviously TLO
and mana are above Grandmaster level and
and we played them just before Christmas
and we won those two matches ten nil so
we play four to five game matches which
we won five nil and five nil we then
showed the replays of that I was
commentated on online some of you may
have seen it in January we were tried
one exhibition match which we actually
lost which we tried to a new interface
different way of processing the screen
and we're still working on that now but
overall our system is extremely strong
so that's alpha star now if we now take
a look at all of our work together we've
you know we've talked we've we talked
about in the past that we started off
with atari games so we sort of crack
that in 2014 with dqn then there's
alphago alpha 0 and now alpha star and I
think in terms of Grand Challenges for
games I feel like we sort of done it now
that that's that's the I'm not going to
clear victory lie Tommy was saying but I
feel like I feel like that we've done
most of the interesting problems that
were inheriting games of course there's
still other things other kinds of games
games like diplomacy that need lots of
language understanding there's some
other interesting things to explore but
we feel like we've we've we've done a
lot of the core work that was needed now
there are many interesting issues with
these systems I haven't got time to talk
about all of these right now so I think
we started a bit late but so we may have
to overrun a bit but this there's you
know one of the things that that was
interesting about these systems and we
learn about these systems is with alpha
go especially the first version of
alphago it lost game four in this famous
match we played against Lisa thought we
won 4-1 and the one it lost it basically
got very confused and Lisa thought that
this amazing move on mu 79 that confused
our evaluation system so when we went
back and analyzed afterwards you know we
were trying to figure out why what was
it about that position that had
confused alpha go and it wasn't so clear
what we could we could sort of tell
though some motifs about the position
but it wasn't we wasn't clear exactly
what the problem was and we had another
match against the Chinese number one
that we that we won in 2017 that we had
to prepare for and obviously he had seen
kou Jay had seen what happened and Lisa
door match so we had to fix this
weakness so you can think of it as a
little bit like a bug if it was a
traditional program and on to this
additional program you would just write
a new rule or something to fix that that
that hole in the knowledge database if
you like but the problem is is this is a
self learning system so we we can't
really just fix it with some you know
some patch we have to kind of encourage
it somehow to explore this area of the
search space explore this sort of area
of the regime and that's that's a pretty
tricky thing to coax a system to do and
actually you know people interested we
could talk about this in the Q&A there
are lots of interesting ideas we had
there of how to do that and I think
there's going to be an interesting
notion of what debugging is when it
comes to these new kinds of systems
right what is the bugging mean when you
have a problem with one of your self
learning systems I think this is really
interesting I think it's a whole kind of
new paradigm there to look at in
computer science I've talked a little
bit about covering the knowledge search
space is sort of related to this first
point how do you know you've covered you
know the whole surface area of what you
thought you were doing you know is there
a good mathematical way of describing
that this also goes links in with
understanding the system so these
systems are incredible incredibly good
at what they do
they have all this amazing implicit
knowledge that they built up for
themselves but how do we understand how
it's making those decisions and then
there's you know maybe philosophical
questions about the nature of creativity
and what that means you know I've
started thinking about three levels of
creativity now and maybe you know
there's probably others but I thinking
about interpolation extrapolation and
then kinda like out-of-the-box
creativity or innovation and there's
three types of things you can do there
and and I would claim that alphago
exhibited some aspects of creativity so
you know was able to come up with new
moves that even human players had never
thought of or seen before so I would say
that's extrapolation
not just interpolation but you know it
can't do full out-of-the-box innovation
thinking like it you know
alphago cannot invent go right that's
what I think we're eventually after
can't invent chess alpha zero right we
can just play some it can create
creative moos new moves novel moves and
novel ideas in chess but it can't invent
chess yet so um and of course i want to
say despite all these successes many of
the most interesting challenges are left
right and i won't go through each of
these but these are just some of the
ones that i think all of you should be
working on and we're working on and i'm
sure many of you are unsupervised
learning memory one-shot learning
imagination based planning with
generative models learning abstractions
and abstract concepts transfer learning
language understanding all unsolved and
and we need to crack these problems if
we want to get to full AGI and so i
think actually in some ways is the most
exciting time to be in the field right
now because i feel like we've just done
the preliminaries we've got the you know
we got we've got onto the first step and
we've done some interesting things it
looks promising
but now i feel like the next decade or
so it's gonna be about tackling really
the crux of intelligence which i think
as many of these things and things even
beyond this list which i feel like
really the the heart of the intelligence
question so i'm just going to try and
speed up a little bit here but the the
so that's games and that's for us you
know kind of a it's not the closing of a
chapter we're always going to be using
games and simulations forever at deep
mind but it's a big sort of watershed
moment i would say for us in this last
year and and the idea is you know for us
has always been and if you go back to
the 2011 talking that's on the internet
somewhere that that tommy was mentioning
i do talk about games and effects with
our business plan and 2011 and and i
feel we've done a lot of the things i
talked about in that in that and that's
in that lecture and but it's always been
that you know a part of the plan so
games i've always felt and simulations
are the perfect training ground for AI
but the plan is always always to develop
general solutions that could be applied
to real world problems
and i think here is also it's very
exciting in the sense that we've just
now I feel got powerful enough and
mature enough algorithms by now
means anywhere near to you know full AI
but there are already proving themselves
to be useful in many real-world domains
and I think that's another really
fruitful error for all of you to explore
is that how can you apply these systems
to all sorts of applications now and
we've applied it commercially within
Google and elsewhere on lots of things I
won't go into all of these these things
but in healthcare we've done a lot work
on energy and data centers other people
have worked on personalized education
virtual assistant I think that the
possible applications are almost
limitless we've I won't talk spend much
time on this but one of our most recent
pieces of work is we've improved the
wind power again that with the the
wimple uses a lot of wind power and
renewables 700 megawatts and we get I've
got 20% efficiency gain on what they
were getting out of their wind power
using machine learning and some of our
machine learning systems and I'll just
skip the various different aspects of
that so I want to now focus on the last
part of the talk which is so that's
games there's commercial stuff you can
do so that's all great but the thing I'm
really passionate about is this section
which is using AI for scientific
discovery that has always been the
reason that's the reason why I work on
AI and the reason why I started my whole
journey is I wanted to use AI to help us
understand the universe around us better
and so having AI is this incredibly
powerful tool that we as scientists can
leverage so I already think even with
the current systems there which a you
know need lots more improvement as I
just mention in the previous slides but
even even the current systems can be
applied usefully to quite a lot of
scientific problems and I put up here
sort of three key characteristics if you
like or problems that I think would if
they have these characteristics would
already be amenable to this type of
alpha0 like approach so first of all
number one is that the problem in by its
nature is a sort of massive
combinatorial search problem right so if
it's got that kind of character I think
that's well suited to this kind of
system secondly can you express a clear
objective function or metric that you
can then optimize or hillclimb against
right and again many domains is possible
to do that and three are there lots of
ground truth data obviously that's great
but or and or so ideal is and but it can
be all an accurate and efficient
simulator for that domain and if I posit
that you know propose that if those
three things hold then you can probably
use this type of system to help solve
that problem and we ourselves are
doubling down on this we're building a
science team it's around thirty forty
people now deep mine we want it to grow
to about a hundred people if that's
something you're interested in please
come and come and talk to me and and and
apply to us because I think there are a
lot of different areas where we can
apply these kinds of techniques even the
ones we have already today and make some
progress and here's just a sprinkling of
some of the things we've looked at and
in a few cases we've got serious
projects on all the way from genomics
and theorem proving to quantum chemistry
and so on and it's been used
successfully already by us in other
groups in lots of areas exoplanet
discovery are some of their colleagues
at Google have done that discover new
planets nuclear fusion we're looking at
controlling the plasma in and and in
these fusion reactors on health care
like diagnosing a macular degeneration
and even things like chemical synthesis
and material design but I just sort of
final part of my talk I want to talk
about what I think is the most exciting
thing that's happened deep mine in the
last year and that's our program called
alpha fold and alpha fold is our attempt
to solve the protein folding problem
which many of you will know what that is
but for those of you don't this is
basically the protein folding problem
you get proteins are obviously the
fundamental building blocks of life and
all life depends on them including
humans of course and what you start with
is an amino acid sequence on the left
here so there are 20 amino acids in
nature and naturally occurring and these
each one is like a letter and you get
this big string of letters one D string
of letters coming in and what you've got
to do is predict the 3d structure of the
protein from this 1d array of sequence
right and you'd like
to predict the 3dc protein structure and
this is actually a protein structure of
hemoglobin and you can actually see the
little hole here in the middle of the
hemoglobin that carries the oxygen right
so this is kind of amazing I mean
proteins are incredible when you read
into them like what they do and and the
businesses so it's such an important
problem in biology is the structure of
the protein the 3d structure determines
its function right so so if we could
understand or how these protease of
structures we would much better
understand what what these things were
doing and you can think of them as like
you know
Millikan molecular machines so and
there's lots of really cool videos of
proteins working visualized on YouTube
and you can have a look at them though
these are two really cool ones like this
is this produces this is an enzyme in
mitochondria and it produces ATP which
is the basically the energy for all you
all live all living cells and on the
right here is a calcium pump that
replaces calcium it when you exercise
your muscle contraction so they really
like little biomechanical exquisite
biomechanical machines and and I think
if we can solve protein folding and
there are ways of getting structures of
proteins right but it's very painstaking
crystallography you have to do can take
like four or five years to do one
protein and some some proteins are not
crystallizable
but if we could open that up then we
could I think we'll have big impacts on
disease understanding drug discovery and
also synthetic protein design actually
building synthetic versions or
adjustments to these kinds of proteins
so the way we try to do this is by going
to our our deep learning systems and
training a specific new type of system
so just very quickly how this system
worked alpha fold is we had a neural
network and then we basically but we
have this database of thirty thousand
known protein structures that we have
the sequence for obviously but also the
3d structure it's no it's known through
crystallography and other methods and
what we do is we train this neural
network and we takes the the amino acid
sequencing as an input we also augment
the data in in in another way which I
haven't got time to explain but by
comparing the sequence
against naturally-occurring sequences
and so those are the inputs and then the
outputs are predictions of angles of
each each point in the in the protein
and also add ISTA gram which is a
pairwise distance in angstroms between
estimated distance between every pair of
a mean of amino acids in that sequence
right and these are probability
distributions of angles and distances
and obviously for the training data we
can recreate the angle outputs and add
ISTA gram from the from the actual
structure so this is trained in a
supervised training way and then we have
to do structure optimization so once we
train that neural network we can put a
new never-seen-before
protein structure in and it will output
two outputs the angle of distribution
over angles and add ISTA gram right so
once you have those two things how do
you then end up with a structure and we
tried all sorts of things here including
your networks and RL and simulated
annealing but in the end what's worked
best so far is just a simple quasi
Newton method a numerical optimization
so what you do is you just take you
randomly sample from this distribution
of angles that gives you a distal am you
compare that against the the output of
the neural network that gives you two
scores you also include a chemistry
score band eval score which stops atoms
being put on top of each other so that's
calculated just through basic chemistry
and that's all combined together into a
total score V and then you you carry on
hill climbing against this total score
till you can't optimize it any further
and then you output the candidate
structure now we're actually working on
we feel like there will be some of these
neural network methods will work better
ultimately than just just the Newton
method but right now that's our current
best method and this is what a protein
looks like as it's getting folded so you
saw it initially if we stop wait for the
start of the gift file so it starts
unstretched and then this is the
optimization folding it more and more
and there's smaller and smaller changes
as the as the optimization process
continues until there's nothing left
Optima
she'll be shortly and then that would be
the output candidate structure so that's
how it looks sort of visualized and so
how do we test this system yes we tested
it on CASP 13 which is the kind of like
the Olympics of protein folding you can
think of it's held biennially every two
years and it's been going since 1994 all
the top research groups around the world
in this field compete so that 100 plus
international research groups and it's a
pretty fun competition because what
happens is it's happened over the last
summer once the competition starts they
have what in biology they're they're
trying to find the structure these
proteins all the time using
crystallography and so when a new person
fight when a new group finds a structure
of a new protein they before they
published it if it comes if it's around
the time of a caste competition they'll
give the structure to the competition
and it's and it's not being published
yet right so we have that you have the
ground truth the competition organizers
have the ground truth but none of the
teams know it right so it's a truly
blind test and it's quite fun so every
day for that three months you get
emailed an amino acid sequence and then
you have three weeks to scramble to
submit a candidate right and then the
next one comes in the next day and it's
pretty fun for the Assoc was pretty fun
to work on so so there's about 80 amino
acids sequences that you get like this
and then you you know you're supposed to
hand back these predicted structures and
so to cut a sort of long story short we
won the competition kind of pretty
unexpectedly and here is the ground
truth okay coming we only have one
person on the team that has ever worked
on protein sequences so but but he's but
he's very good he leads the team John
John John John called John jumper and
and so the graduates in green and you
can see our predicted in blue and you
know through these are three of the the
proteins that we folded pretty well and
they're pretty overlapping as you can
see and but we didn't just win we won by
quite a big margin so we won 25 of the
43 protein categories that we were
proteins that were in the category were
competing which was the hardest category
and the net
best team only won three out of 43 and
also if you look at the average you know
this is us on the purple bar is another
very good team here and then it's pretty
linear after that so you know we're good
like 25% better than even the
second-best team and then another so
this really shows that these methods I
mean obviously there's a bunch of it's
been going on for twenty years so
there's a huge amount of careful
handcrafted systems in this area like
there was in chess right so and
obviously this is just a learning system
and then here's another graph which is
shows you basically this is the angstrom
and angstroms 0.1 of a nanometer the
angstrom error of each base in the in
the sequence each amino acid in the
sequence each residue and these orange
lines are all the other teams this
Purple Line is us and this is that this
is the angstrom error and this is the
percent of residues percent of amino
acid sequence that sort of in bases that
are have that much error in them so you
can see all up to like 98% that we're
within 10 angstroms so so that's pretty
cool and so you know and so this is
great for me because it's really we've
been I've been talking about applying AI
to science for a long time but this is
really our first proof of concept that
this really could work and in a really
important area of science that would
have a lot of impact and and I want to
just carry out this is so we are state
of the art and we know you saw the
graphs and we won the competition but
we're still a long way away from this
problem being solved and by solved I
mean useful for biologists so they don't
have to do crystallography anymore or at
least as much and you'll still need to
do obviously to check the ground truth
but as much and what they tell us is
they want neither one angstrom error is
the kind of tolerance they can deal with
so we're still quite a long way away
from being within one angstrom across
the board and so we're continuing on
this project and it's one of the biggest
projects we've got going at the moment
and we're exploring many many additional
techniques I hope to when everyone our
next come here to have some new results
on that so I'm just going to finish by
talking about the bigger picture a
couple of slides on that and then we'll
go to Q&A so so I feel like we're making
good progress now on this thesis that
always had that AI is a kind of meta
solution I feel like in science and in
many other areas of our lives
information overload and system
complexity are two of the biggest
challenges we will try to overcome
especially in the sciences and I feel
like we've all got a lot of data big
data sort of everywhere and for a long
time people were talking about big data
as being great but I think it's sort of
kind of the problem so we've got all
this data almost everywhere we look but
how do we find the insights and process
that data how do we how do we look for
the right things inside that data and
make sense of it and I think AI is
potentially very powerful answer to that
and the way I think about it is that
intelligence can be thought of as a
process a kind of automated process that
converts unstructured information into
useful knowledge and my dream is to make
a I assisted science possible to allow
us to make faster breakthroughs and you
know it's it's a very very exciting time
right now with it and I think AI holds
an incredible promise for us as a
society but I just a couple of notes of
caution you know we like with any
powerful tool we've got to make sure we
build AI responsibly and for the benefit
of everyone we build it responsibly and
safely and you know I think as with any
powerful technology it's inherently
neutral in of itself it depends on how
we as humans and our society decide
we're going to deploy it and I think a
lot more research and discussion is
needed on the impact of this technology
and if your interests in researching
these topics like robustness and bias
and safety please let us know we're
because we're again we're expanding our
work on that front and we've done a lot
of collaborative work with outside teams
and companies like the partnership on AI
to try and increase this and as a final
slide as a sort of the neuroscientist in
me and we were just discussing this
yesterday CBMM I think trying to build
AI with the neuroscience inspiration
behind it and neuro plausibility is a
great way to actually understand the
mind better ultimately because if we can
distill up AI and intelligence into an
algorithmic construct maybe we can then
compare it to the human mind and then
that will unveil us allow us to better
understand mysteries like creativity
dreaming and consciousness that we want
to understand about our own minds so
thanks for listening I just want to
thank everybody
all these amazing people at deepmind who
worked on all these different projects
and thank you all for listening
[Applause]
[Music]